welcome back circa the brand new resort
being built in downtown las vegas it's
just
one week away from its grand opening and
just a few hours ago the project's much
talked about garage mahal was unveiled
hector mejia is there live for us and
remain in fremont with a live look hey
hector
hey there and the unveiling of the
garage mahal was for a rideshare driver
so they can get used to the new space
and here we see
employees standing by waiting for those
drivers to keep on driving through
throughout the afternoon
and right over in this direction look at
that that is an art piece
that says the time of your life just
hanging right next to those escalators
that lead up to the casino floor
this is actually our first look of the
area the garage mahal calls itself an
innovative transportation hub designed
specifically with rideshare
traffic in mind it has almost 1 000
parking spots
and this is a preview of what's to come
on october 28th
at midnight that's when circa opens the
casino floor
we're told it'll employ up to thirteen
hundred people
that number will increase to nearly
sixteen hundred total employees
when the tower opens in late december
with hotel rooms before new year's eve
derek stevens owner of the d hotel and
casino is behind circa
which by the way is the first resort
getting built from scratch
since 1980 here in downtown las vegas
i spoke to a circa employee who is happy
to be part of the opening
he is providing jobs for thousands
even though we are an epidemic he wants
to show us that
circa is here for them we're a place we
can enjoy ourselves and our friends and
family that does visit
las vegas and hopefully circle will
bring life back into downtown
there's been a lot of buzz around circa
it's been in the making for at least
five years the 21 and over property will
have the world's largest
sports book six pools and 700 plus rooms
and if you're wondering about employment
we're told
circa is still hiring the garage mahal
is open to rideshare drivers until six
o'clock
this evening reporting from downtown
we'll be back right after the break